welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
[Applause]
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos a couple announcements
before we start the show the first make
sure you guys like And subscribe to the
channel our goal is to get to a thousand
likes and we're actually going to open
up the chat so right now it's members
only but if everyone wants to chat get
to a thousand likes and we will open it
up
the second is that we have two clips
channels Pearl daily and just pearly
Clips make sure you go subscribe to both
um also guys we have four membership
tiers the first tier you get to be a
part of the chat second here you get to
have access to our Discord and our
behind the scenes Vlogs one of which has
me freestyling so if you want to see me
freestyle get the second tier um third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media and fourth year you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month a
lot of people use this if they want to
grow on YouTube I've gotten a million
subscribers in a year
um we actually have the one year for
anniversary for the show I think
next week so yeah if you want to know
how I did that sign up for
the fourth tier uh my Instagram got
taken away so so follow my new one just
pearly things one
um we have Rumble now so make sure you
guys go follow our Rumble account we
also have the wife wife School Channel
which I have been doing with Auntie
where I learned to need what did I
learned to need bread yeah yeah
she really wanted it but it's not that
kind of need
I learned ever need bread last week so
if you want to see me learn how to need
bread um that's on the wife's School
Channel we also have a new channel which
is an animation Channel it takes some of
our clips and it animates them also guys
we only have one official pre-game
Instagram so any other Instagrams that
are claiming to be me I just have just
pearly things one and I have the
pre-game show those are just the
Instagrams that we have
um okay yeah that is all the
announcements so um today I have a
lovely panel so why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself starting here and then go
around the room hey hello I'm submarine
I am 19 years old and I'm a full-time
student and I am single
um a fun fact about me is I like to
watch Cars go around for an hour only
getting two seconds screen time so yeah
hi my name's Rachel I am 39 I'm single
my fun fact is I don't eat any fruits
and vegetables and my second fun fact is
I make skin cream out of animal fats
wait you don't eat any fruits and
vegetables so what is it just bread and
meat no just meat oh you just eat meat
me me eggs butter and salt wow yeah
that's just like have you got a name on
Instagram Carnival Fitness yeah Oh I
thought yeah all right that's what I
thought to myself I've seen your page
before yeah good for you amazing I
healed all my health issues with that I
mean I couldn't believe she was 39. yeah
I've seen on these I've seen her on
Instagram
might try that if I can look like that
at 39. everyone should try it everyone
okay go ahead hi I'm Louise I'm 21. I am
in a relationship I'm a full-time
student and um fun fact I'm actually at
the beginning of a weight loss Journey
um so far I've lost roughly 100 pounds
wow wow
[Music]
um so yeah that's my fun fact it's going
fairly well definitely got quite a lot
to go but it feels good to be on the
track to being healthy 100
hi my name is Carmen
um I'm 25 I'm a full-time mom and
fun fact about me
oh gosh I'm just crazy literally
everything country is crazy I have an
example like what's one crazy thing
um so there's no extreme with me so if
I'm doing something I'm going hard okay
so
craze is crazy as in like my drive to do
anything because so what's what's
something crazy you did this week um oh
uh told a few people about themselves
and not held back on how I feel so who
who was it a couple of close friends
ex-friends oh yeah you lost all your
friends this week there was my friends
last week
that crazy okay all right Auntie go
ahead
she's crazy too
Jimmy
um
you don't look um fun facts
I'm not learning about
social media believe it or not thanks to
Bill and I don't like it
well tell them tell them about your
channel too oh yeah see I keep on
forgetting and I've got a um YouTube
channel Auntie Jenny American Auntie
Jenny with a Y because you know
Americans can't spell
um yeah Auntie Jennifer Y and um
um nearly 40 000 subscribers
a couple of months too she's grown
faster than I did when I first started
so she's she's killing the game because
my mouth is bigger
laughs
so I'm Daniela I am 39
um I am single and fun fact about me
um I used to play the saxophone
and I can't vouch that the carnival diet
does work
because
she's my coach
and my best friend
hi I'm Marie I'm 25.
single and a fun fact about me is
um full-time mum part-time eyelash Tech
got you okay thank you all for coming so
uh today's topic who wins after breakups
men or women
so Tom Brady and Gisele I'm sorry guys I
can never say her last name Boon Chen
I'm officially divorced on October 28
2022. legal teams from both say that and
not an ironclad prenup agreement was put
in place before they were married in
2009 making the financial aspects of the
divorce relatively smooth what has
happened since is there what has
happened since then and why are they
both in the new sense Giselle has been
linked with her children's Jujitsu
instructor Joe main Valentine a 42 year
old Brazilian man with some speculating
that they have had something going on
before the official divorce he started
appearing on giselle's social media
around February showing Giselle basic
techniques on Instagram he has also been
seen traveling with Giselle and the
children since the beginning of the year
Tom Brady 45 officially confirmed that
he is dating Veronica rajak a 26 year
old Slovakian model with over 3.2
million Instagram followers she she has
attended a few of a few of his games and
has taken photographs wearing his jersey
Gerard Peak and Shakira were in a
relationship from 2011 to 2022 having
two children during that time after
breaking up in 2022
Gerard Peak 36 years old has been
confirmed to be in a relationship with
23 year old Clara Chia Marty
Shakira has moved from Spain to her
family's home in Miami Florida and has
been linked to her 24 year old surfing
instructor custody of the children is
still pending this begs the question who
normally wins after high profile
breakups men or women
so we'll start here and then go around a
man or woman I actually I think I
managed to hear what other people got to
say first I can't lie Okay who wants
anyone opinionated want to start come
come on just depends on how that what
the situation is so if there's obviously
kids involved
[Music]
um
and high profile breakups oh
I say mendu okay yeah because
it's like no matter what the the
publicity just sort of like dies down on
them whereas women they get it a lot
more
that makes sense
I don't know
so how I explain it so like some men
have more publicity after they say they
get publicity
um
but it's not as much as like it wouldn't
go as long as what the woman's publicity
would go on for if that makes sense so
like there would be more Paparazzi
watching the wimp the woman
um her every move who she's dealt with
and then sort of like you'd hear once in
a blue moon if the man decides to leave
and show off that he's got a new woman
then they would catch him but it's like
a one-off one-off story and then that's
it bye okay so you would dictate who
wins and loses after the breakup by who
has less publicity
yeah because it good all publicities can
be good but comes with bad as well a lot
of negative okay
I think after a high profile breakout
Pride the women
the the Outlook from the society that
they get is kind of crazy I think they
get told that they're not good for fine
moving on and finding someone else so
and also it's mostly men
in high profile breakups that money is
associated with as well so as soon as
the female goes and finds another
Partners always she like she doesn't
bother in the relationship she get it
and that's what I think and it's kind of
that's true if one a woman's moving from
relationship to relationship to
relationship then maybe she isn't the
best fit or the best candidate for a
relationship
I think a woman that moves from
relationship to a relationship knows
what she wants in a relationship because
I'm going to tell you not a lot of
people out there like are gonna be what
you want them to be so move I would say
personally move around as much as you
want until you find the right one
couldn't you figure that out before a
relationship like by asking certain
questions
um some things you have to live to
actually know because some people they
know stuff but in order how they apply
it practically is completely different
you can know so much but once you get
into a relationship it's way more
sacrifices way more compromisation that
gets involved that I think
is important and if you need to move
around as much as much relationships as
you need to to get that security to
finally understand that these situations
won't work for you then that's what you
might need to do and I think the more
women do get looked weirdly for that but
is what you've got to do at the end of
the day men do it too so do you think a
guy is a good candidate for a
relationship if he's constantly having
failed situationships with women like if
he if he's maybe in a two-year span
dated like 20 girls do you think it's
likely he's going to date you
sorry I mean if I know Ahmad has dated
20 women otherwise she come date me I'd
kind of be like and but then it kind of
contradicts what I just said yeah but at
the same time as a man if a woman has
gone through 30 men and came up to me
and said I wanna have a relationship
with you I'd kind of be that what's up
you know and also as much as I said
compromisation is required there are
stuff you have to learn and go through
sometimes you have to stick in a
relationship for you to actually make
stuff work it doesn't necessarily be
moving on to other ones but just because
you moved on from relationship
relationship to relationship it doesn't
mean you're crazy
so
okay go ahead
um either of you you go ahead okay sorry
um so was this question reserved
specifically for high profile
relationships or uh just relationships
can you tell me your opinion on both
high profile and regular yeah sure so
high profile I think is a little bit
worse because say we've um also can't
pronounce the name Gisele Bundchen the
things that's how you say it
um Tom Brady it's he's probably going to
be one of the most wealthy top 10 type
of men that she'll ever be with and
because women we're hyper hypergamous by
Nature we typically can't date down and
she would struggle to find someone
especially at her age now that she has
children unfortunately and that would
give her what she wants which will
probably be marriage
um so I think that applies to most high
profile relationships because they have
some form of Celebrity Status therefore
their Partners will probably be a notch
ahead of them uh
whereas for normal people like us
um I think women generally unfortunately
still do losing a break in a breakup
um in the short term they're winning
because they can find a Sim to buy them
a bag and take them places and they can
find men to fit different roles of a
partner but in the long term they would
lose because they'll struggle to
actually find someone who wants to be
with them and vice versa and they'll
probably get to say 35 No Children
because they've been playing the field
whereas if they stayed in the
relationship providing it's not abusive
you know the exceptions to the rule and
they tried to make it work it probably
could have been happier
in the long term
I don't necessarily think that a breakup
means that you're gonna start sleeping
around start dating around I think some
women do wait I've find men do move on
pretty quick and they seem to not be as
picky
I do think that they move on a bit
quicker
um I don't know I
I'm unsure of my opinion because there's
so many different variables like do they
have kids do they are they married were
they together for a long time I'm just
saying if there's a hundred high-profile
breakups who typically high profile who
typically wins men or women can it be
none of them because there's so much
drama around it
oh okay
um
I think the woman the woman yeah tell me
why because as I said the man moves on
very quick and he's not as picky and he
can seem to get a lot younger partner
than than a woman would if a woman's had
children then there's that too
um the women lose
what did the women lose yeah it seems
like you're saying the man should get
like a younger what I'm saying is that
they can't move on maybe they want a
relationship after that breakup and it's
harder for them because they have
children maybe
um and then there's more to consider
it's not just black and white even
though the man has children as well when
they move on that's that doesn't seem to
hinder their day and experience they can
still date and move on and do what they
want it doesn't stop that
so it's just based on what you said it
sounds like you're saying that the women
lose and the men win yeah okay okay you
said the opposite when you started I
thought I said no I thought I said that
the women lose
I thought am I crazy maybe maybe yeah
maybe you did okay um go ahead
I think it's it is a difficult one it is
a broad one
um I think in if you're looking at high
profile celebrity status and breakups
um
I think generally depending on how they
break up I think it depicts on how it
would end up but probably women would
lose in terms of emotionally I think
especially if there's children as well
um pretty much
in times of
men I don't think they're emotionally
attached as much as women I think women
tend to be more emotionally attached
than men so
in a breakup I think when women break up
they break up way before they actually
physically break up with a man where
there's a man
I think they're quite flippant and they
will do it spare in the moment it's how
they're feeling so I think in terms of
who generally wins I would probably say
men in that aspect because I feel like
they're mentally there way before women
are probably there
okay what do you think
um
see I think the opposite to you I feel
like a woman knows in her head that
she's gonna break up with a guy before
she's actually gonna do it yeah like the
other way around
I think yeah you just repeated it
exactly what she said my bad
um so yeah I feel like
when it comes to actually breaking up
I feel like women are more prepared for
that actually happening
then I don't think men think to
especially if they're comfortable in the
relationship
they're not really
thinking about it too tough so I would
say maybe men lose more because
I just think they're gonna they don't
see it coming as often do you think men
are more hurt after breakups than women
like women move on quicker Yeah okay or
like
they start that process before yeah
because by the time the woman does it
she's been thinking about it for six
months what do you think about dating
options after do you think who do you
think typically has more dating options
after a relationship men or women
I think it depends on the man of the
woman right so in high profile cases
um
again I think it depends on the if you
had to pick one
maybe men in high profile okay cases
because I think for a high profile man
you'll have more women wanting to
do Elfie then the other way around
Auntie what do you think
at first I was in sight
before you brought the sixes into it I
was gonna say the person with
the most money
wins initially because they're out of it
but then the women
but they actually it's the man and he's
got most money and they split up then
the woman might think she's winning
because she gets like money and the kids
and whatever
but then she's
less attractive
to the outside world so she might
thought she's a win she might think
she's one initially
but then I think the men in the end win
because they can get any woman out there
that they want younger that looks a
whole lot better than the old bag that
they've left so you know all the stretch
marks and everything's gone because when
you look at all of those whoever had the
most money
got someone younger
and even though their partner's gone and
football yeah like um
what do you call the the guy the perfume
the aftershave Guy what's his name the
one you just mentioned Tom Brady yeah
that's him
I don't know then I have to shave names
like that or something
you're thinking oh sorry yeah
okay I know it's something to do with
sports but
he split up and she's gone and she's got
this guy so when they said about women I
find that in the public eye sometimes
the women move them faster because
remember that's cautious because they've
lost a lot of money so they're not
moving on fast but afterwards they can
get a younger person
so the women were got there and they
would say oh we're going to get married
again are we going to get hooked up
we're going to settle down and I'm going
to just go out there and get a young
lady and play the field because they can
so the women might lose that you know
the men lose out more financially but in
the long run of course they got lucky
they can go and get any young bird that
they want because when you're a mature
man and you've got money you're
attractive unlike
the women out there that got money
because like if they don't they don't
look all that all the plastic surgery
and stuff that they need to keep up
their looks but maybe just work out and
they'll still look good
can I say something
um Tom Brady so if you've specified it's
a high profile breakup then I'm guessing
we're talking about money here most of
the time I talk about popularity yeah
um can I ask when they actually got
divorced do you know when
um officially October 2022
okay okay right because I was gonna say
because as an athlete Tom Brady's
Spotlight the reason why hidden
Spotlight is always going to constantly
change like when he when he said he was
going to retire the spotlight was on
just retiring ain't nobody mentioned
about him breaking up but
I don't it was all over the like my
YouTube feed yeah like it was it was
just on um right Megan Kelly just did a
special on it yeah right so I think my
main point so I'm trying to say here is
that the spotlight as an athlete but Tom
Brady is going to change constantly so
people are gonna eventually forget that
he's been divorced if he moves on with
another person so I think for the female
it's more so like she's the one that
broke up if Tom Brady is such a big deal
and I think the hate that's gonna come
for the women is more than it is for the
men just considering the fact that he's
such a high profile athlete would you
say in society men are valued more for
what they build where women are more
valued for the relationships they can
keep 100 100 because Tom Brady can now
design crazy and invest in this many
stuff invest like a billion dollar
company maybe that's what's gonna be
that's what he's going to be in the
spotlight for or it's like Elon Musk I
mean how many baby mothers does he have
but yeah Noah each to their own isn't it
but no one really talks about it right
but if the roles were reversed and it
was a woman and she had the same company
but she had like three I don't know how
many he has but like three four baby
fathers people would still look at her
funny no matter how successful she is
it's gonna be long for her and that's
just how it is unfortunately but
have any of you ever looked at an ex's
Instagram or Facebook to see how they're
doing after a breakup yeah all the time
has anyone ever done that anyone
two two okay so the majority what do you
what do you I shouldn't put my hand up
really because nobody I've been out on
Facebook
I think
I think yeah I haven't do you guys get
mad if the girl you feel like is
prettier than you or better looking not
just happy you're you're happy for that
yeah
it depends on how soon after yeah break
up yeah so how how soon would would piss
you off versus how soon would make you
happy for them
after she's moved on yeah
[Laughter]
does it depend on the X too like how
much you liked the X whether you're
happy for them or mad no no just have to
move on so I I kind of look at life as
lessons so for me not to be with someone
I mean it's taken me a while to get here
to be fair but it's my stance now it
wasn't previously possibly maybe before
but
I think everyone
there's a reason behind everything and a
why and I think
if we're not meant to be together then
we're not meant to be together
be happy
good luck to the next person
that's just kind of mad I mean I don't
wish you the best
it's taking me a long while to get here
but yeah I just think yeah completely
understand that as well if it's a bad
breakup you think you've seen with
somebody else you think yeah she I'm
glad she's got you I ain't got you yeah
it works both ways but then if it was a
good breakup you know you just split you
just fit to yourself
okay I've got you there you deserve her
because she ain't gonna be as good as me
but well done
because women are [__]
you're not going to say you're going to
be happy for someone who's proud of them
come on but it's a bad breakup better
than a good one
I don't know it's about what do you mean
it's about like if I if I know was to
break up with someone there's either two
ways I can break up one we have like the
most craziest fight and I say [__] you
and I leave or it could be right we're
gonna sit down and talk we're gonna
figure this out why it didn't work out
by the end of the day I just don't want
to be with you and it's both on both
parties it's the same what's going to
help me like in which circumstance am I
going to be like yeah you know what if
you moved on to another girl I'll be
like yeah good for you do you get it
because either way if if we end up in a
fight and you left I'll be like good for
you so which would you prefer the bad
breakup or the
amicable okay sit down and talk like I
that's what I'd prefer anyways well
sometimes if it's a bad breakup it's
just like it makes you get over it
faster you think so that's why I'd
prefer the bad ones because it's just
like done and out of the way I mean it's
like you don't because you don't want to
deal with the drama of it but at the
same time then you're just over it
you've got things to say I don't think
that was a bad breakup what Intel is a
bad breakup because it sounds all crazy
can I hear what everybody's what's your
worst breakup ever been like
um because it sounds like you said
they're doing something crazy
just broke into my flat after I ended it
too much I think two months after I
ended it he broke into my flat and hid
in my wardrobe oh my god wow
okay okay
she spoke you're looking over there
okay so so okay
who broke up with who I so it was quite
bad I ended it with him but he had
nowhere to go and I said oh I will
support you you lived to get was your
bum
was he living with you yeah I was paying
the rent okay okay
um
was it was he hot
how tall was he damn it should have been
too long just you don't say that to her
you say was he good in bed
I was better in bed no one day broke in
okay okay so you break up with him then
what happens
um so I supported him
through the breakup obviously so he
could get his own place because I knew
if I kicked him out he'd turn back up on
my doorstep
don't want that so he moved out
everything was fine I was even praying
to God like please just let this go
nicely he left
about two a month later I'm hearing my
name outside my house I'm thinking
what the hell called in my family
everyone's saying are you sure you're
not having a mental breakdown
they actually believed I was losing my
my mind
um and then on my birthday which was
like a month after that
it broke into my house he was hiding in
my wardrobe and um
yeah it just went like he he didn't come
out but I could smell him in my house
how long was he there I don't know no
seriously because he was outside and I
ran up the night I took my heels off and
run up four flights of stairs and then
I've gone in shut the door behind me and
everyone's trying to get in and I was
just like when I find you
it's over
um I could just smell him on my flat and
I couldn't find him and then I left and
he broke out afterwards
I've heard of a woman breaking into a
man's but it's the first time I've ever
man breaking Auntie what are you doing
if someone stands at your house like
that and comes inside until yeah now
you're inside your mind
That's the Law That's the Law isn't it
my property your inside I never invited
you you know I'm I'm not leaving you
have to get past me
are we fighting them
I'm gonna fight and I'm defending myself
because I'm at the door there's a
difference
legally that's what I mean I know what
I'm saying I know what I'm saying
what else who else anyone yeah crazy
wake up worst breakup is it worse
breakup or is it worth the person if the
person is bad now the worst breakup I
want to hear yeah
I want to hear that I say oh they're
nice breakups do they ever nice breakups
has anyone had a nice breakup I've had a
nice breakup I love you yeah most of
them have been nice yes there is there
is such thing as nice breakup guys
tell me about the one that wasn't nice
what happened
uh do I really want to go into that
um I'll just move over it did you do it
yeah so
way back in my past I'm not gonna go to
my recent way back in my past
um I had someone that was a bit
obsessive actually
he left he finished the relationship and
then
he thought he could go away for the
weekend mess around a bit and come back
and I've had enough and I said No and
then
um
he was fined him in the streets on his
hands and knees crying begging you know
yeah it's a bit messy
and he would try and break in but he
didn't ever succeed he was trying to
break it yeah he put a ladder up to the
window and also there was a lot
there was a lot yeah he didn't he didn't
get in but it was weird
yeah
so he put a ladder onto your door and
tried to uh to the second yeah and then
tried to get
yeah did you call the cops
did I collect do you know it was a long
time no I don't think I did I think I
just
got out of the way of the wind he
couldn't get in so what was he gonna do
it's just stupid it was just such a
stupid thing to do okay you go off a
ladder go back down again see ya yeah so
all right have fun wow that's I can't
believe there's two people in here yeah
he didn't succeed though and he didn't
hide in a wardrobe
I mean he did do some weird things over
the year but I'm not gonna go into stuff
okay
um is dating a younger more attractive
man than your ex considered a win why or
why not
doesn't it depend on how he treats you
and what person he is um how he carries
himself whether he's holding doors open
for you whether all those nice things
that you like from a man to be treated
like a woman
um is he doing those things does age
really matter
can I just say if I was to date a
younger guy then I am like was dating or
I'm dating whatever the situation may be
I'd probably catch a case
it's crazy
you've got no leeway I've got some
leeway the question's based on the
um Tom Brady so okay she was dating a 24
year old what do you mean
she's 40 something I mean I don't know
if I'd want to date a man that's that
much younger because it takes a mess it
takes men a while they have to get some
things out of their system before they
settle down and
yeah they mature a lot slower I don't
know if I'd want to do that a little bit
and you've got to look at his are you
actually looking to have a are you
footage younger person you're actually
looking to have a relationship I don't I
don't date without having a relationship
I don't get involved with anyone unless
I see a relationship potential I don't
do that sorry one thing that I would
point out is women typically don't want
younger men and attractivists and what
secondary
um I think for men
if they had a you know a younger more
attractive
um new person than their ex then it
would be a win for them because that is
kind of their dating metric that's what
they look for whereas with women I would
typically look for someone that's older
like my partner's a little older than me
um
and attraction you know a lot of times
women can replace that with for example
you know status or money whereas with
men if you're not attractive they won't
even give you the time of the day so it
is the question was kind of asked in
Reverse it wouldn't be you know a win
for women but definitely for men I think
I think that it'd be a win for women if
I mean the younger person as a younger
person if the younger person was a
more mature
because sometimes you get a younger man
he's more mature than the other man
you've left is it rare it's rare though
isn't it
am I everything
yeah but it's the man rare I know you're
a rarity but no sometimes no there's a
lot of good young men out there no but
then if you're actively going out
seeking a younger guy saying oh yeah
this is going to make my husband thought
[__] like I'm gonna go with that he's
gonna be like oh he's probably more
sexually active probably more
good-looking probably has better things
coming for him I think that's kind of
that's kind of low-key tapped like high
key in fact like if you're thinking
about getting with someone to degrade
someone that you've been with before it
kind of just shows your character and I
don't think that's how we should be
approaching it especially right now and
as women I don't think that's how we
should approach it before we get labeled
our stuff we don't want to so I agree I
think that's good I agree for the
different reason that's slag Behavior
if it's if it's like a 40 year old woman
and a 25 year old man what could what
future could there be no matter how nice
of a young man he is she'll get good sex
for about 10 years before he leaves her
I'll I'll be up for that
then we went to the next one but no I
mean okay
so would you say that's a win then for
her oh it's a win for her
good honor that's nice
I'm gonna talk about equality in it and
that the younger man oh good on him he's
out there if I know the woman has got a
bit of dush why not
I think some men like older women
and I don't know whether it's mummy
issues but I feel like they like to be
mothered and I think older women
tend to wrap them up and look after them
yeah no no I just think that older women
knows how to look after a man rather
than the young people nowadays so what
you might see as mother it might be just
a traditional woman looking after a man
and that's what it is because if you get
an older woman there and she decides to
go and give a man dinner on a go and
cook dinner and put it on the tree you'd
be like
to I mean and you might think oh she's
my friend name but that's what women do
well and younger guys like the guys that
I know that will go for older women is
typically because they want casual sex
and they just think it's easier to get
it from them yeah that's what I said
good sex for 10 years
[Laughter]
and if it lasts longer that's a bonus
would you guys ever date someone for a
long period of time knowing there's no
long-term future
[Music]
basically
no no absolutely not waste of time
you're wasting your youth yeah
don't do it don't you think you may want
to pass in past like someone who's right
for you maybe you may miss them whilst
wasting a few minutes
catch them again what I said if you miss
no she was saying that I'd rather next
one comes along yeah because I'm sorry
but if you're with someone and you're
just think you know what I mean just
thinking realistically you've don't have
anyone and let time for us you by and
then I'll use that right there all your
roses and your lips and whatever or you
find a young man and you just think you
know what I've got you for five years
well I've got a man for five years and
just enjoy yourself you're not looking
for nothing else you might be a busy
businesswoman that don't want a
relationship
and you might have come to an agreement
with someone you know what we're just
gonna
see each other but
we got five ten years to waste I
personally think that only worked for a
short period of time you can only be so
uncertain for a short period of time and
that initially happens at the beginning
maybe like give it three four months
you'll probably start liking them and
being like yeah I want to get into a
relationship but then they're going to
use the fact that you went into a
relationship without no intention of
getting together in the future to
basically go yeah no I'm not really
getting into one that's one of my
mistakes that women make right so I
think that only works for a short period
of time it can only be uncertain for a
very short period of time sooner or
later you will end up liking the person
believe it or not how soon will you guys
have that conversation of where
something is going
foreign
you guys do on the first date third date
a month in depends who they all
does it not depend on before you even
get to that point knowing where you're
actually at in terms of wanting a
relationship or not
well I'm saying if you want to be in
something long term yeah and you're
gonna you meet a guy and go on a date
with him how long till you ask him where
it's going
um for me personally it would be before
we become intimate or like I shared that
kind of energy
you just said before you come into it so
how many dates you're going to go on
before you come intimate I'm just
thinking about the guy could be taking
you out like four or five times and then
you're gonna tell her and I said no you
know I'll be vexed if I was a man I'm
taking you out on five dates and you're
going to talk about getting that for it
I'm gonna be vexed let's be honest I'm
gonna be Vex that I'm on to you really
you're already dating
think about it from a man's point of
view you like this girl
and you're talking you're going to take
her out on these dates and then after
the fifth date she's gonna be like you
know what um I can't really see a future
I'll be like give my money back you know
I mean I'm wasting my money on you give
my money back I think it should be done
like from day one by the time you
started talking like yeah what's your
name and I'm date with intention you but
like me or you don't like me move on but
to go on dates and then turn around and
say
that I thought you should get keep all
the receipts and that's his money back
at least 50 but for someone to say that
you really must not have liked the dates
that day you're probably just focusing
on trying to get a different type of
intimacy with a person no the question
was how long would it be before like if
you're gonna get serious with someone so
to go on date she's asking when that I
remember I said to someone like when you
meet someone they want to take you out
say you know what are your intentions
towards me I think I'm dating with the
attention before you even go out on a
date for the time you're going out on a
date you're the you're giving them false
hope you're giving the man thought so
from the time you said yes I'm gonna go
on a date you're thinking yeah I'm in
there and then the next day yeah I'm in
there I'm getting closer I'm clocking
goes now you're not my type after four
or five days
I actually do you think that's what I
was trying to say before it's I think
it's before knowing before you get to
that point
what you want going into whether you're
going to have a date or going into a
relationship I think women know you can
just look at a man and see you know even
before Uganda that you know so when you
go on a date you already know you can
tell by the first date that you don't
like him I mean I kind of maybe
and I think we do feel that and we do
know prior to going forth with anything
else so I do think those that say I just
want to see and wait and see how it goes
on I think deep down we we truly know
before we even go to that point instead
of saying no I'm gonna go on dates with
him because something better might come
along
but sometimes you can know someone's not
right but you're highly attracted to
them so you keep going back
you know some people well there's a lot
of people that sleep around they know
yeah
like a friend of benefit I feel like if
you get into a situationship where
you're basically your friends with
benefits you've kind of already
established what is going on in the
relationship right
but
I feel like if you're
before you even go on a date personally
I'd speak to the person first probably
like give it like a week give it like a
week or two you'd know if you even want
to go on a date that's the thing but for
you to go on five dates and be like yeah
I'm not I'm not yeah I can see that if
I'm being honest a man has to make my
fanny flower if you're not making my
money
I feel like there's nowhere to go like
there has to be that sexual chemistry as
well as that energy and that connection
I think it has to be there I think it is
important yeah but don't forget like
your family can flutter at the beginning
no I'm saying don't follow you funny but
I have to have that funny flutter with
somebody that I'm gonna be looking I
think that's important part of if I hit
that's got to be in my shopping basket
but being able to that physical
attraction that sexual attraction with a
man as well as being able to have that
intellectual conversation and
have that fun Factor as well I think
there's a lot of so what's not in the
shopping bag what are you willing to
give up
because because if he's a good looking
guy that makes your like Fanny flutter a
lot of women are going to want him so
can I say what I want in my basket and
then everything else can't be in my
basket okay go ahead go ahead
um I think honesty is important I think
communication is key
um
I think I'm at a point in my life now
where I need consistency
um to feel safe and secure
and obviously that physical attraction
have fun what I don't want is somebody
dictating to me telling me what I can
and can't do
um abusive whichever way shape or form
that may look
um so yeah I think that's a shopping
surely Dave and a basket
yeah so I think you know that's that's
me
what about you guys
what would you guys want to go
I have everything I want now
it's not gonna be cringe but I can't be
like well I want this because I'm tired
so don't have it no
um he looks after me he leaves me he
does everything I need thankfully is he
more than five years older than you
uh yeah well he's five years older than
me see that was a good guess
what would I want
um you know I used to be big on saying I
want communication anybody that asked me
what I wanted I'd always be like I'm the
best Communicator in the world I need
someone to communicate just as well as
me but you realize that communication
comes in different forms and it's always
not going to be compatible with you so
even when someone is you'd think they
wouldn't be you're asking a man to be a
woman
asking telling you to tell me what you
want is not asking me to be a woman I'm
just telling you so that you don't get
upset if I don't do the stuff you want
me to do how many men have told you to
shut up and be quiet
nobody and I hope no one
okay yeah you're lucky yeah
um well a lot of the time I'm not gonna
stand someone listening to shut up for a
lot of time if men tell us what they
really want we leave because it's
usually um have sex with multiple people
and you stay America so when we get told
that that's their form of honest
communication and we're just like all
right I'm going that's probably why
they're not honest with us
she's got a shopping truly I want to
find out what everybody else wants okay
so good communicator what else
someone that I find
attractive okay is there is there a
height requirement for that you're not
that tall I don't think I'm five free
um no I don't have a high requirement
you can be as tall as you like five five
foot five foot I don't think I'll go for
some of this
yeah just not sure what they're me sorry
yes no uh hat requirement but just
someone that's not sure than me okay
just because I feel like I'd be more
attracted to someone that was taller
than me than sure same height is good
same height can be yeah it can be all
right we can drink for like five five at
least yeah yeah okay okay go ahead so
tall good Com or five five and up and
good communicator yeah someone does they
said it's so funny someone that I'd
prefer if I was to look for anybody and
I've from the first time I even stepped
my foot into this dating World
um someone that's been in a previous
relationship
but however I don't mean it in a way
where like you're still talking to them
but I mean in a way where like
um you know what is required in a
relationship you know how to go about
someone a significant other and how to
talk to them how to look after them and
I think yeah so I think that's kind of
important to me no no I don't break car
but I would prefer that okay so five
five and taller has been in a
relationship good communicator or
anything else
maybe something I'm not allowed to say
on camera
I'm Jake I'm Jake but yeah that's all I
got for the top of my head though okay
now what about you so I would say I'd
like someone to be honest
and if even if that is brutally honest I
prefer that
um
someone that is considerate
uh someone that I'm attracted to first
of all
that's my number one and then the rest
kind of follows I'm a bit more like
um
I don't mind relaxing some of my wants
if the person is a decent person if he's
got drive if he likes to enjoy life if
he sees
um fun in being alive appreciates being
alive that's
things can change I'm not so black on
white on things like I've I have dated
okay I was young but I've dated someone
that was shorter than me before
um
actually I only have I've only had two
relationships and both weren't all so
it's not like I'm looking to break up
with them or did they break up with you
they both broke up with me okay
um
um so what else anything else but
obviously like I said earlier
um
they come back
when they realize the grass isn't
Greener
um but yeah
would you take them back if someone if
they came back well I did with one
particular one no not anymore though
that option's not even there anyway but
not anymore
can I ask why they broke up with you
is it you or is it them
I would say it could be
so the first person wanted like I said
earlier I wanted to have fun
went off for he could come back
and I didn't let him come back and that
really upset him
um
second person he did keep coming back to
be honest it's a long story we were
dating since like I was 14.
um 14 to 18 broke up dated the other guy
and then got back with him after and we
were dating for
about 12 years with maybe a year Gap in
between that wow you're with him for 12
years yeah with lucky well 13 years with
a year ago in between yeah wow why don't
y'all get married that was the idea yeah
that was the idea yeah most marriages
yeah it was the idea we we lived as you
know as you would
but you know things change people change
and I think sometimes
um when someone's in an environment
where they're with a lot of younger
people they can change what they want so
initially when we first dated
he would and he still would hold all the
doors and everything he's very genuinely
um and he's a very nice person
but he
he would not like it if I attempted to
pay for something he had to pay for
things like he learned to drive because
he didn't like me driving him around he
was saying it sounds amazing he was like
that's I don't feel manly yeah yeah but
at the end when we broke up one of the
reasons he gave is because I don't take
him out on dates and pay for things but
he's in an environment where he hangs
around with younger people and I think
he
and may have got a bit messed up along
the ways he had it right in the
beginning you know um he was very
traditional and I liked that about him
he was a good person he treated his
mouth that's another thing they have to
treat their mum well
um and I think that that speaks volumes
um yeah but times change people grow out
of each other so he because this just
doesn't make sense so he hung around
younger people and then he was married
so he's a he's a musician okay
um and I think when other people say oh
my girlfriend bought me this my
girlfriend done this and took me this
place and then it made him think ah why
isn't she doing that but he would have
been angry if I'd done that originally
um do you think there was other ways
maybe you could have done something that
wasn't money that he would have
appreciated oh yeah I did yeah I did and
he just didn't take that into account
no
maybe not obviously not yeah that sounds
like he was doing stuff not more so to
have the authority not in a bad way but
to have that Authority be like yeah I
can look after you but kind of just
dismiss the fact that he wanted to be
look after too so maybe that's what he
came back and went cool like you don't
look after me but like for him his only
like his only intention was to look
after you well I don't think I don't
know me based on what I'm hearing that's
what it sounds like but yeah based on
what I'm hearing he got easily
influenced by his peers and that's what
it was he spent more time with his
younger peers listening to them and
sometimes becoming hard peer pressure
can come at any age yeah I think
especially as you were to give us so
young and he was so it seems like he was
mature when he was young and then he
spent most of his youth being mature and
then when he had the chance to be young
again and be a teenager because he'd
lost all his teenage years he just went
for it because he was surrounded by that
I think if he wasn't a musician it would
have been different but being a musician
that's hard yeah I made him be a
musician as well all right I was like do
it follow you yeah do it it's fine I can
you know take care of things for a
little while that's such a long
relationship it just sounds like such a
it's seemingly smaller thing that and
such a long run oh no there was many
there was many things
um there was many things that he'd done
at the end that were not good but I
don't really want he's a good person
I've got nothing bad to say about him
but he act he behaved badly for a little
while for like six months of our
relationship you behave very badly
um and then he's now back to being
normal and everything you know fine I
but he yeah he was a different person
I've got fingers crossed for you yeah no
no no no no I'm rooting for it no hell
no you won't mature yeah no no how old
is he now
he's 40 when he so it was when he was
turning is he with anyone I don't know
he would I don't think he would ever
tell me that's the thing I think he
would you didn't creep no you didn't
check his page
I haven't recently obviously when we
first broke up I looked would it make
you feel we're still on we're still
friends on everything we haven't done
that would it make you feel a type of
way if he told you he was talking to
someone else right now no not at all I'm
completely healed like literally
when he moved out I came to terms of it
pretty quick and I am one of those
people that take things as a lesson and
I move on from it so I'm like I could
see so he's done some really bad things
at the end but he's a good person and I
can see the part I played in that so I
can see how my behavior made him behave
that way
um
so I think you know sometimes it can be
easy to
stop doing the things that you do for
each other
and and not keeping things alive you
know
um and I'm not saying in the bedroom I'm
saying in general day to day
um
yeah so I just think that good people
bad situation things went upside down
and that's that's fine and actually I
think I had my best year of my life
since since we split up funny enough not
because he's a bad person it's just
because
I can be me I can do what I want to do I
don't have to consider a partner's
feelings for a little while
um I'm not the type of person to just
move from person to person
um yeah so I'm just good being me for a
little while
I'm still kind of rooting for it no no
no no no no no okay whatever
um what about you two what do you guys
look for in a guy
okay go ahead I've already answered I
said how everything I want yeah she says
I'm sorry I'm sorry it's okay
I want the truth
because I seem to find myself
in the position where I'm always soon to
be the side bit side [__]
um all the time
and I think that's just what annoys me
like
do you think you give us psychic Vibes
yeah I just don't seem to find someone
that just wants but do you know he's in
a relationship when you meet him no
otherwise I wouldn't go there oh okay so
it's different yeah I just get put in a
position where I find out like months in
one case two years
um that they've been in a relationship
so I just want the truth because it
doesn't hurt me like you could turn
around and say oh this is not serious
and I blah that's it is what it is I
want to have my fun but if why do you
think they put you in that box
I think because I don't necessarily come
I don't come across like I want to have
something serious okay so as much as I
do I'm like in between because I've had
bad experiences before which has made me
feel like I don't want not to live with
me I don't want this I don't want that
but then it comes to I do feel lonely
and I would want that intimacy and that
love from the right person do you think
that that's in a way making the mistakes
of the man of the future pay for the
mistakes of your past
it's kind of like when it's kind of like
when a guy is is always going through
your phone because some girl cheated on
him
in a way
see I always say this rule I won't go
through your phone don't go through my
phone if you see something that's gonna
hurt you don't you think that before you
move on to one more day [__] like like
get rid of the baggage heal from one
before you go don't take one
relationship into the other
can I say I've I've clocked that we've
all been saying honesty but I feel like
personally if you yearn for but like
honesty in a relationship is kind of
like it kind of sucks because like if
you're going to relationship being like
I just want honesty I need you to be
honest with me I need you to be honest
with me it's kind of like do you need to
beg for that but also at the end of the
day I don't know about you guys but
personally for someone that's been
honest with me I have felt hurt before
and it's kind of like also that honestly
doesn't I feel like there's certain
things that you don't have to say
there's certain things that you don't
have to say but if you say it's going to
cause some type of some type of you know
and also can I say guys that are always
honest they normally always honest about
the past relationships and I feel like
if you if you if you've established that
you guys are going to be a hundred
percent about everything you've done
you're gonna feel some type of way
regardless of whether that involved you
or not so they've been doing stuff
before they even knew you but you'd feed
the tap away because they're with you
right now so it's kind of like certain
stuff you don't have to say and it's not
me being secretive if there's certain
stuff that we can talk about we can talk
about that's going to progress our
relationship but if that's about oh like
yeah I used to do like this with her and
like yeah like this and that I think
it's kind of like I think you're right I
don't think women want honesty but yeah
because then they wouldn't keep dating
Liars yeah yeah and be like yeah I want
you to be 100 honest with me but I feel
honest to be honest cheaters I would
rather just cry and be mad and then just
get over it my first reaction always say
tell me the honest truth let the first
reaction go over the head because that's
it soaking in yeah that's the honesty
progress your relationship is it
positive to your relationship though yes
because they know that there's no point
in lying to me I'm not the one you want
to lie to and why'd you say honesty when
I asked when you I asked you what you
were looking for because to me that
implies that maybe you haven't always
gotten that no I haven't
um the past relationships
well because you're a pretty girl you
have a million options there's many men
that will be honest with you but it's
like we pick the Liars no they they I
don't know I just feel like they as you
said make more funny so okay it's like
the Liars the lies make you want them
but then you're attracted to the life
yeah
so then what incentive do men have to be
honest with us if the Liars get laid I
just prefer like if you just turn around
and said yeah you're seeing talking to
like two free other girls and I'm just
an option at the moment if they told you
that then they then you wouldn't sleep
with them that kind of links back to
what I said earlier
um a lot of time and this has been
mentioned on fresh and fit another
podcast
um when we want honestly honesty but
as the saying goes they can't really
handle the truth because when you are
honest
they immediately leave which you know I
understand what what incentive is there
for men to be honest because they'll
lose the resources they put into you you
know whether it's taking on dates life
advice everything because men help us
with a lot of things when we're with
them
um but then you just leave because
they're with other people which is most
likely the thing that they're not being
honest about and so as you said what
incentive do they have to be honest when
they could lose the whole thing they've
put work into like you must be crazy to
not tell me something that you know I'm
gonna be like yeah I'm Gonna Leave You
for it's kind of like what people are
selfish I mean do you do you go into
relationships telling when your body
count
well it depends anyone ever asked I've
never been asked because never I don't
know because I feel like any guy that
you talk to these day will ask you your
body count really not really not anymore
maybe like two years maybe young people
anymore
she's right it's a young person it's
like the youngest the younger the guys
yeah maybe it's because yeah but I'm
just saying if we're going to be a
hundred percent honest no no because I
feel like
especially right like a lot of girls are
with guys where they know if they said
their body count it would end their
relationship so so like there's there's
in a way we're not always honest with
them either because I was gonna say like
if you're going into relationship
nowadays especially like my friends
everybody that I'm surrounded by right
now as a 19 year old they will 100 ask
your body count 100 it's one of the
first thing that comes up what's your
name what school do you go what's your
favorite color what's your body count
it's definitely the age maybe it's the
age thing but in this like in this day
and age right now that I'm in right now
they will ask you with no shame because
when you answer that's the question will
you answer 100 I'll be straight up baby
I'll say this many I don't know I've
never had anybody ask me that older men
just don't see the point and asking yeah
maybe they just feel like you're gonna
lie anyway you're right but the last
time I ever got asked that question I
think I was 16 years old that's a good
nine years ago really because
I lied I did get answers all the time
right now and I did give my honest
answer I think with men as well
um obviously you know you can't look at
a woman and be like oh yeah her body
can't exists but you can get an inkling
of whether it's higher or lower and
sometimes that is enough to suffice them
as to whether they get in a relationship
or just have sex you or whatever it may
be I think how you portray yourself is
sometimes enough for them to decide
would it put you off of this if their
body can was like higher than yours
if my partner man's body knows how the
moan no of course not you know I think
men value inexperience whereas women
value experience so my partner's body
characters of course higher than mine
and if it wasn't I'd be like why the
hell am I with you if no one else wants
you but did the young lady on the inside
I don't think that I don't agree with
that but I just expect men you don't
agree with what that
um you think it's because the experience
I I don't think you don't think women
value experience no no I do think they
value experience but I don't think I'd
be saying oh your body count is less
than mine so I don't like that because
other women don't like you can I I mean
I don't know that's a conscious thing
but I mean yeah I don't I don't sit
there and think of myself well these
women didn't you've got a low body count
therefore these women didn't like you so
why am I it's just you know a silent
tick in your head where it's you know
it's like Evolution
it's like when a guy's very I mean one
of guys will tell me getting verified is
the first way to get women yeah because
it's a sign of pre-selection
so superficial though isn't it I mean we
can't really change it yeah it's like
it's like telling the world not to be
the world and all in all of history like
women have gone for men that other women
have selected so it's like you can say
it's superficial but that's that's
always what happens yeah like look at um
you know Genghis Khan all the world's
conquerors if women didn't like men that
weren't if women did not like men that
were experienced why do these men that
you have harms of women women just
naturally gravitate 17 women reproduced
for one man every one man eight thousand
years ago
has to say crazy girls can get who they
want and guys get what they want no
girls get what they want guys get like
if a guy can only get a girl if the girl
wants them he can't just go out and get
the girl girls
can get who they can I see um sorry guys
sorry
um I feel like just we were talking
about there's like a couple seconds ago
but like I feel like women always say
they want to experience someone who's
experienced
but we'll cry if they find out who
they've been in those experiences with
and how many body count there is can I
just say it because I could say and be
like I want someone who's so experienced
that's going to do this that's going to
do that and make me feel this type of
way but then as soon as okay cool that
happens and they're like okay cool like
what's your body can't who have you been
in for the past they're gonna start
crying and it's kind of like
choose choose whether you want him to be
experienced and and like is that common
100.
I just want to hear we've been that
scared the question about what she wants
in the math oh yeah what do you look for
what do I look for Animals yes
um I feel like even though I'm quite
small
I'd say like five eight
um sorry I'm like five three I've got
two little people
[Music]
normally I feel short next to Pearl I
feel tall today
um I like command that's family very big
on like family
um big family
I like chivalry
I don't really have like a type like
physically so he's got to be five eight
and he likes his family and chivalry
well he's nice yeah he's got good family
and he's chivalrous what about money
any minimum what if he's unemployed
are you paying the bills till until he
figures it depends on how much passion
he has and what he's doing that's not
paying the bills
it's like really a big thing usually
unemployed people don't have passion
typically
I'll tell you all right welcome to
England
so are we all going to say like money is
a big thing in a relationship going into
a relationship right now like yeah money
is a big thing
I've heard everybody mention everything
and for me all I want is a man that's
working that's going to treat me the
same way he'd like to be treated and
he's got to be good in bed
I ain't got nothing I don't care what
you look like I don't care how tall you
are if you're not good in but it ain't
happening I don't care how much money
you've got either if you know and
everybody's talking talking about this
funny flower I mean that funny
fluttering and nobody said about sex
what but so your funny conflict and the
man's gonna tell me you ain't gonna be
good in bed what are you gonna do then
he's got everything else that's in the
shopping trolley except that because now
you put that you need to put that in the
shopping Charlie I missed that off but
that is vital absolutely you guys rather
have a guy that you weren't physically
attracted to that's good and bad or a
guy that you were very physically
attracted to but he was bad and bad give
me that I'm not physical
yeah I don't mind because I feel like if
you're not good in bed I can always do
that kind of a bit myself working for me
so you you would take the hot guy
yeah you take the Hawkeye what about you
I think I I think I'd have to be
attracted to him to some degree to be
able to lay down so I'd have to teach I
think rather than not have an attractive
man no there's no this isn't build a man
tomorrow
60 Seconds
[Laughter]
I mean I think that's important for me
that would have to be good in bed so
but then I wouldn't be able to lay with
somebody if I didn't find them
attractive that's difficult and pick one
come on you have to
be ugly and good in bed and good looking
and rubbish
oh you didn't tell me they can't get up
an ugly man
is that how superficial you are I mean
I think um
it's tough I can't answer I said I never
got that because I always if you get an
ugly man nobody's gonna want him you've
got a whole man for yourself
but then he's not making my fanny
flutter so then it's not but they're
doing it for me so I think I would have
to I would have to yeah maybe but then I
have to look at him it's the good
looking to have to look he has to be
attractive to me and how many hours a
day are you looking at each other versus
how many hours a day are you sleeping
with each other
if you're working if you're going out
together you see it you it's yeah how
many days how many hours a day do you
work about eight how many hours a day do
you sleep about eight that's what you've
got to think about so you're only gonna
see him back before and depending on
sexual positions you don't even have to
look at him
I think
I think I'd have to go with with the
good looking guy that's superficial
isn't it but I think I would have to
yeah most women would there yeah I think
okay would anyone take the the not so
good looking guy we're good and bad me
all right you too and then you would
take the Hawkeye yeah I've actually been
with someone that's not good looking but
it was good in bed and then after a
while it's like my mind just started
saying to me they're good looking it's
all right
is fine it makes up for it in the beds
no I go for the person that's
unattractive but good in bed because you
can learn to love someone's appearance
even if they don't change you can just
gradually learn to love it whereas sex
is quite an intimate part of
relationship so even though it's not as
important for women as it is for men
generally
um it's that'll still be a part of your
relationship missing
um
how many relationships have you guys
ended and why
I've only been in one so and it's not
ended so zero
three three three and why'd you end them
um it just wasn't good towards me all
violent
oh violent you did it three Violent Men
yeah stupid Please
first time it's okay like you wonder
like yeah okay it happens to anyone
second time I should have seen the red
flags but I didn't and now the third
time I just feel like I need to write
muggle my forehead do you know men that
aren't violent no I do I know a lot of
men which are my friends it just makes
no sense I just go for the ones that
they show they're nice at first and then
it's like once they grab hold of me
they don't want me to go so they'll do
anything in any type of force I.E and
you saw no red flags in the beginning
a couple two of them yes uh one of them
no I just like Wonder because if I was a
guy listening to this I'd be like why
would I be nice to you because you don't
like like you know the nice guys but you
don't pick them you just keep um if
anything like it would incentivize them
to be abusive so that's the thing I
think like
normally like I would feel like a guy
would come to me thinking oh she's been
in free relationships that have just
been violent but I've actually had
nothing but good guys to come towards me
since I just I've been taking my time
whether I want to be in a relationship
with someone or not because I really
don't want to go to a fourth time and
that's it I will be getting mug tattooed
on my forehead yeah
um what about you
you're only 19. yeah
um have I ended a religion I have ended
one
um and I think I ended it just because I
think I just wasn't I wasn't ready for
the commitment
um yeah
fickle
I think I just wasn't ready I think it
was kind of like
I was just like yeah nah and it kind of
just shut me off completely like after
that it was kind of like I don't know
why I did it nothing it's just
completely cut off and it was like I
didn't feel the same way anymore
and that was literally the end of it
there's no more to that than it than I'm
saying but yeah
I think we you said you would too
relationships and you ended one no no I
don't know they ended both I'm more of a
stay in a relationship make it work kind
of person then jump off and give up
by having said that the first person
wasn't a great person so once he left
and he had made that choice it was taken
away from me so then I could then go and
be happy so I was actually grateful that
he ended it and that's why I didn't let
him come back I actually understand that
thinking because when it's like if they
break up with you you don't really have
a choice in it so you don't have to like
guess if it was the right choice because
it wasn't your choice yeah it's easier
to detach when someone else breaks up
with you than it is to for you to break
up with them do you think women ever try
to get guys to break up with them yeah
100 yeah everything I feel like that
happens all the time I feel like if
you're in a relationship where you just
feel like it's kind of like he's
sometimes maybe a bit more committed but
maybe not in the way that you want it to
be you're probably going to do
everything in your power for him to be
like yeah I'm not trying like you're
doing Madness whereas that's not
actually you but it's kind of like
you're provoking that because it's just
like you don't it's kind of like you see
it but then at the same time you don't
and it's like it's easier like I can't
cool it off because he has valid points
so therefore I'm going to provoke
whatever situation it is to make him
break up with me so that I can just be
like cool you broke up with me and I'll
leave it as it is and just let them case
rest uh yeah I just want to jump off
something that you said a moment ago
where um a lot of time say if you get
broken up with it's easier for you to
move on
um I kind of think with women it's the
opposite because when we break up with
someone we break up with them with them
in our head and then you know six weeks
later then we break up with them so I
thought perhaps it'd be a little easier
if we leave someone because often we've
planned it you know for a lot of women
there's a guy already waiting
um whereas if you get broken up with
especially if you think things are going
fine it's this you know complete change
of circumstances sprung upon you so I
thought perhaps I'd make it a little
worse actually yeah you're probably
right actually now that I'm thinking
about it because if things were going
well like that probably would devastate
me yeah yeah but it's kind of like if
you're are fighting already you know if
you're fighting already you've probably
mentally checked out as well you just
wait for one of the other person to do
it I actually do agree with you on that
one yeah like that's never happened when
it was like it was you know
do you think that women detach quicker
than men
depends on a woman
I feel like okay
I feel like women detach quicker than
men most of the time like if she has 10
relationships like eight or nine of them
but there's like one guy that like she
cannot detach from okay like like and I
use it because you can see it in pop
culture like 100 a lot of the movies
that like women love like Titanic The
Notebook what is it what is it about
about that guy it's like the lady in the
Titanic is like 90 talking about her
High School fling yeah and she's still
talking about that and same with the
notebook it's her going back to that guy
from high school yeah so I feel like
unless it's like that guy like women
typically get over it easier than Matt
but if you're like that guy to her then
she doesn't
um I thought the reason why I say women
get over men quickly is because I think
be aware more of an emotional we're
going through more of an emotional time
than men are
um
I feel like you're in certain situations
where if something happens it's kind of
like you feel it way more than you would
feel than a significant other would feel
and then
yeah fair enough no I thought so I'm
talking more from my experience is what
I'm trying to say I feel like there's
I'm a very emotional person if something
happens
um my emotions is in a 100 and it's kind
of like if something keeps happening
I'll kind of I'll kind of get used to it
and I'll kind of be like whoever so if
so if you're involved in a relationship
where like things will keep constantly
happening they'll get to a point you
like you'll actually get to a point
where you're kind of like yeah like he
could do something and I just completely
like I won't react the same way anymore
and it kind of just you just like the
relationship will end and it kind of
just like cool whatever because you
already felt what you need to felt
during the relationship so why she's not
going through heartbreak after I think
women just underestimate men's emotions
yeah I think women are just out there
crying and blubbering and whatever and
the men just take it because if they had
to turn around and crime blubber I mean
every other man and there must be women
that square with men and they just start
crying what did you think about them
lose total respect for them yeah that's
why they don't do it they just deal with
him but women got them all their friends
will come around and always done this so
he's done that and then try let's try
some drama so he's telling me women lose
respect for men that Crow would cry to
you oh my God yeah of course I swear you
wanna okay you want a guy leading you
imagine the CEO of a company just crying
in front of his employees it's the same
thing with the relationship you're not
going to respect a guy's leadership the
same way if he's crying all the time can
I ask because I might have acquired in
front of you
um I've had people be emotional towards
me and it hasn't made me really lose
respect for you because I feel like a
fair both like established that type of
relationship you can't cry to me I'll
look at you like cool let me put it this
way right you use with a man and you
tell me you don't want to be with him
anymore and he starts crying and
blubbering what would you do how would
you feel that's kind of different that's
what we mean that's what we're talking
about even my pride wouldn't let me cry
for someone if they broke up with me
I thought you said that you that women
cry and get emotional when they get when
they were split up with a man
pardon I thought you said that women
crying they get emotional when they
split up with a man I mean they do right
so I'm saying turning on it said what if
it was a man that's better with a woman
and he's the one that's blubbering
I mean cool cool like if you're joking
then you care didn't it like I don't I
don't know what you actually want me to
do how would you feel towards him do you
think it'd make you want to get back
with him and then like would you be more
attracted to him or less attracted to
him
it depends on who it is yeah if he yeah
it depends on who it is if you look ugly
crying though sorry
but yeah it actually depends who it is
like 100 but I think that girls usually
and I can say this from having not from
my own experience but from friends who
go through this uh one of our friends
um said to me when we're on first time
um that she had an argument with her
boyfriend
um and essentially she did it just to
see if he would like kind of chase after
him FaceTime or uncaller and you know lo
and behold 50 no caller ID calls and she
said to me well like I don't really want
him to be doing that like I want to go
after him and I thought it was quite
strange because you know you'd think
that you'd want someone to come after
you and you know chase after but
typically you know women are attracted
unfortunately to toxicity so
um yeah but is it not toxic to be
harassing someone like that of course
that's of course that's toxic
um but I'm saying in terms of
in terms of the relationship
um a lot of time
how to explain it
um it's toxic to be harassing someone
and but it's also you know toxic to
leave someone that you love with no
final word which is what she would see
that relationship as but for some reason
that's what she would gravitate more to
than someone that's trying to get her
back yeah that's what that's what I
meant I'm a cut and go you lied to me
I'm gone you cheat I'm gone
[Laughter]
what have you told you or like cool I
saw us together but I had to go confide
another woman to make me realize that
you're the one I'm looking for I'm gonna
keep on going and then keep on thinking
no if you lied to me from the beginning
you have to set the rules down from the
beginning and if I have a man you know
don't lie to me don't you if you lie
it's over if you cheat it's over I don't
care why
is over finishing no conversation is
done because women say oh you know if he
cheats on me you know and then what he's
going to do again he's gonna do again
he's gonna do it again if I told you
once it's gone it's finished it's gone
and if you cry it's even worse and
you're even stupid to believe him if he
says he's never gonna do it again but
what if he doesn't do it men most
probably wouldn't but that's my line my
line is like no
no I've seen it happen too many times
girl goes back cheats some more I would
rather just not look like a clown what
would you say most girls go back after
they get cheated on some not all what
percent how many friends do you know
that I've gotten cheated on
ah
um all of them
how colorful but it was the situation
that they had been in so let's say if it
involved kids obviously they want to put
the kids first you know I mean um no I
know there's reasons I'm just curious
yeah but I don't think I think after
they've been cheated on once they start
where I'm such a the type of person I am
and the way I handle things obviously
the people around me
they've done dumb stupid things like
I've done stupid things in the past
I'd just be friends of yours have gotten
cheated
and shoot a couple so two three yeah
three three and how many stayed with him
after he cheated
um two two but they've not they're not
with them anymore right so they just
meant like when they cheated they stayed
yeah they stayed with them afterwards
but then they left that obviously yeah
yeah later yeah
proves my point
um okay uh
I don't even remember the original
question because you haven't been down
here yet no I know because I was
thinking would you remember what the
question yeah it was something to the
type of men
I think it was
have you separated from men or how many
men have you seen right yeah how many
breakups have you initiated and why
so my
first one
I left but it nearly cost me my life
um my second one I
it was I was seeing someone and he
was seeing other women so that ended
um and my third one I was just a huge
secret
so that ended in November
so like his family and friends didn't
know about you no okay so you felt like
you wanted something more serious and it
was more casual for him yeah I think so
um it was four years that I was with him
so
if you don't mind me asking how did you
almost lose your life in the first one
uh
domestic abuse
physical abuse
um
all abuse
yeah I was basically isolated
um
come on big question on live TV
yeah that's I have accounts over it um
I've got two beautiful girls
um amazing girls who blessed me with
those
um certainly taught me a lesson huge one
and one that nearly cost me in my life
um
but yeah I was with him for a long time
I don't know why I stayed I think
mentally and emotionally I think abusers
have a way of
the physical disappears
the mental and emotional abuse stays
um
I was so isolated from everybody and I
think in terms of
I only had him and his family so it was
quite difficult and I think
the good was good
the bad was horrific
so
um were you able to press charges
I didn't for a very long time but I
don't think
I dealt with it and healed from it until
years later
um in fact it was only up until a few
years ago so I finally left in 2010
um so 13 years ago and I only really
dealt with it and got support for it
about five five years ago and dealt with
it so I think it was
I up and moved the police removed me
from my home
um it was going to go to court we did go
to court
um they said I wouldn't see him at court
I did see him at court and then that's
when I withdrew all my statements so he
still got prosecuted I think now they
can prosecute yeah um
but at the time that wasn't the case I
think he just he got a fine in probation
and community service and stuff like
that so
um and I think for me they told me I was
looking at five years and we had two
girls so you wanted him to not that I
wanted him back but I just thought for
the girls right but now looking back
that was the wrong decision I think he's
gone on to have multiple abusive
relationships since though but um my
girls have had nothing to do with him so
that's kind of yeah yeah my youngest one
did seek him out but
he's not changed so um
she no longer wants a relationship with
him my eldest one remembers too much
definitely doesn't want anything to do
with him at this stage but I would never
not promote that I think that's
something that they would need to make a
decision for at the time I stopped them
from having that relationship for their
own safety and mine
um I've never stopped it in terms of if
you wanted to do it
properly and down the legal route
um supervised contact absolutely but
he's never wanted to take that so
um it was all about control and about me
so the times that he did have contact
with the girls in the early years when I
left
he would be screaming at the girls for
them to put me on the phone so it was
never really about the girls anyway so
so yeah so that was my first one
thank you for sharing that
um okay I'm I'm curious like how many
years were you with him before you left
was it did you say seven so from the age
of 18 to
28 oh wow wow that's a long time yeah so
just because I'm always just curious
like when did you realize he was abusive
so it was gradual so after probably
about the first eight months seven
months eight months
um
but it was little things can't go out
didn't want me to go to work but made it
made me feel like it was I was doing
something wrong all the time having male
friends why have you got so many male
friends just yeah it's the Ice Station
why are you wearing that that doesn't
look nice on you you don't need to wear
heels today why have you got makeup on
you're going just little things
you know I come down in something that I
want to wear I don't really look nice
babe why don't go change it
little things but then obviously
past relationships his own insecurities
obviously knowing people that I had had
a relationship with previously
we could be watching telly it could be
anything that triggered him it didn't
matter what it was then
um but physically
yeah about after about seven eight
months
oh
so what what made you stay that long
good question
good question I don't know okay I don't
know the good times were good I think in
terms of
I don't have any real answer maybe I
thought I loved him I thought he loved
me
um
always sorry he would always be sorry
for the things that happened and
make things up buy things take me out
say nice things to me pillow talk I
guess if you like
um
yeah I follow in situations like that if
you don't mind me just saying what I'm
about to say but it's kind of like when
you've experienced such lulls any high
will seem like the happiest thing on
Earth for you and it will make you want
to stay so it doesn't matter like how
however long how long they've been
together how long bad stuff has been
happening but if the high is high then
you're you are going to stay believe it
or not it's going to take a lot of
Detachment it's going to take a lot of
like self-discipline for you to be like
for you to kind of go this High isn't
the high we want this this high is only
High because the lows have been so low I
disagree I I disagree someone that's
going to assuming the situation
sometimes you never know what day the
week is let alone high as a high and
it's all about picking away at you so by
the end of it you've got no identity you
almost probably just his partner and the
kid's mum and these things creep up on
you I mean I put up with it for I think
less than a year but and in my day you
call the police he was like oh it's a
domestic they've never done anything in
those days so it's probably for 10 years
wow I had police at my house the police
just come regular and just say oh it's a
domestic I need this leave and you put
hanging them in there you're supposed to
take him with you
I never did
the only most you're going to get out of
your Social Services so back then it
wasn't even that no but you didn't even
get that back there was nothing then and
I mean I didn't have my son then when I
did that my son and I thought that's it
I'm out of there yeah but it's like
especially when things happen around his
family not yours and that's the weird
thing is you feed yourself how can you
have a family and they know what's going
on but they won't do anything and then
you realize that the whole family's
scared of him yeah that's what I think
it's going to ask him was this family
kind of complicit in the abuse they knew
what was going on and they just turned a
blind eye or was it secret to them
they were aware they didn't condone it
um there was one incident where his his
mum did say that
she's the that brought him into the
world she'll be there to take him take
him out obviously but that was because
it was right in front of her
um
majority of the time I would spend time
at his mum's
um In fairness and she was amazing and
she was she's been in a great amazing
grandmother
um to the girl so
they they know their identity they know
where they come from and they know his
entire family the only person that
they've not had contact with is him
um so that's their choice as an adult
whether they want to go back there or
not
um my elders remember stuff she shared
stuff with her younger sister I've had
to try and protect her younger sister
from that but they are sisters they will
talk yeah I won't lie to them
but I don't need to divulge anymore that
it's not been said if that makes sense
so that's
how did you break it off because we know
we're talking about breaking off like
how did you actually break off I went
into a woman's Refuge okay you've done
the midnight flip I did had a bad bad
ready
the first so the first time I was
removed by the police
um they came and removed me and they
took me to my mum's but then after a few
months
I went back but there was a
normalization order in place it wasn't
allowed in certain in the area he wasn't
allowed back at the property but then as
time lapsed
two years later
I put myself back into a woman's Refuge
um and just left
and then I've never looked back and
obviously I had a really good judge that
done an injunction out with a clause but
in order to in order to cancel the
injunction we both have to be at call
oh and it's 37 years late and I don't
think he realized it still stands I mean
there's no trouble now but it still
stands no I didn't I didn't he wasn't
allowed in the area but it was only for
a period of time
um I can't I think it was about six
months maybe even a year but he breached
out anyway but
um when I went back the second time I
just 21st January 2010.
never look back
cut my hair changed everything about me
just feels good fresh stuff amazing so
yeah
then the second one that was a
three-year relationship but that was
wasn't really going anywhere I wasn't it
was just
something for me at the time I think I
had the girls it wasn't something that I
was really looking to commit to anyway
but
I found out he was seeing multiple women
so it just kind of ended but my last one
I do love him still
um but it's not worked out I'm not
prepared to be a secret for any longer
um celery it is what it is we move on
did you just say right it's finished
now there's been a lot of back and forth
um
we've just not spoke
um he knows how I feel about certain
things so
we've just not communicated would you
say you like bad boys it seems like all
of the guys you pick seem to be bad boys
what's a bad boy like non-committal
multiple girls I mean usually I wouldn't
say the majority of bad boys are abusive
but in her case that would probably
qualify
I think sometimes we can pick partners
that are
possibly a reflection of how we feel
about ourselves sometimes or what we're
missing
um
I don't know I'm work I'm on a I'm on a
journey at the moment I'm healing and
I'm learning a lot about myself and
about
I'm doing a lot of inner child work I'm
looking at myself going back through my
history why do I pick the men
that I have I do come from a broken home
is it generational is it one of those
things that just my upbringings impacted
that the influences around I I don't
know I'm doing a lot of work on that at
the moment because I do think it does
impact on our decision making and our
judgments
[Music]
um
how we brought up how childhood I think
it plays a huge part
[Music]
um
perhaps and how we develop just to put a
smile in your face but it's a nice
question it's still smiling you see it
was a question would you would you get
to give him a vegetarian
[Laughter]
vegetarian yeah
you're perfect guy and he said I'm a
vegetarian
it's not perfect okay
you don't know why I asked right yeah
okay yeah
yeah
that's a young lady about dumping men
how many relationships have um you ended
and why
are we like three or four
um
I think most of it is like
just not
what I want I guess like it's just not
working or they're just
I like when someone knows the diff
obviously I like someone that does isn't
too serious all the time but I feel like
knowing when to be serious is so
important so that's like one of the big
things for me
and what about the other ones
yeah it's just don't get along or one I
actually end up falling in love with
someone else
so cut that off
how did that start was it someone you
knew like a guy friend I know actually
it was a girlfriend
yeah we just
became friends
ship
like we got closer as friends
um and then yeah
I didn't expect that um
everybody like I'm thinking what the
hell
it's hard to say it I was shocked
shocked everyone always is I don't know
why like what is it no because this is
the way you know we're all talking I
think you just naturally explained yeah
we're just expected
and then when you said it is that I
noticed that you could hear a pin drop
and I thought
[Laughter]
he's like I lost my girlfriend
I'm a female I didn't see that coming
have you guys ever dated a guy and he
turned to out he swung for the other
team no yeah no but who said yes yes
how did you find out
a couple people and
um let's just say the streets the
streets talk the streets talk you know
everything
everything so you heard through the
grapevine he was like hooking up with
dudes
that and I've seen obviously things
myself obviously at first I was a bit
suspicious and then you know did you
have particular sexual positions I just
want to put it out there nicely
I have to ask people out there
because
you know they're more freaking out
they're much more freakier okay it's
much more dirty I just said don't say
dirty
but I like that okay
um weirdly
would you go with somebody that a
bisexual person again yeah I would okay
they have to be male or female both
I didn't sleep with girls as well okay
I'm not saying that no date see I'm just
asking
um out of the breakups are there any
breakups that you considered a win and
why
all of them all of them yeah you always
did better after
better okay yeah yeah yeah
were there any that you considered a
loss
one one yeah my baby dad probably
um not him
did he did he go on to date someone else
no he's not I think it's just in terms
of like
him as a man
probably like one of the best I'm going
to get so now that that's not there I
think that's where I've kind of
got a loss because do you think um him
being your baby that influences that a
lot more
influences what just the fact that you
you feel like he was like the best you
can get
[Music]
um
so if you didn't have the kid would you
still feel the exact same meals you're
feeling right now yeah because I just
feel like in terms of the qualities that
he has as a man
is it too late for years too okay
I don't know if he's watching this
he's Brave about this that I want you
back
[Laughter]
yeah yeah Auntie Jenny is actually
Auntie Jenny's actually doing counseling
now as a YouTube show so if you want to
bring something yeah
oh I think it can work I think that you
see the differences right when you when
you have somebody like that and you got
that same kind of feeling what you need
to do is go back and sit down and talk
about what went wrong what you could
have said
and nine times out of 10 you find that
as a woman you need to apologize because
you didn't let him be a man and I can
tell by your face that he was right and
you was wrong that's why you're often
because you realize that you left up
yeah
you can see by your face am I am I right
or am I right
I say like 80 yeah okay then let's take
that
that was impressive
it's not the medicine
[Laughter]
I mean
it's not that I don't like him but I
just feel like there's certain things
that because he's only well I'm 25 he's
going to be 20
27 27 or 28. so he's not that much older
than me but I feel like
in in a lot of in like 70 of ways he's
so mature and then there's that 30 where
he's just so immature loving that that's
the fun bit are you are you immature at
times you don't think you're ever
immature he's not God
you know what she needs to do she needs
to think to herself whatever he was
serious 100 of the time
that's what you need to think Effie was
only a hundred percent of the time you
wouldn't feel the same way now
and you might not like it you might not
think so now but those fun bits what
made him the whole person no I do like
it I just feel like there's a time and
like I said earlier there's a time and
place when you need to be serious maybe
you just need to cheat and go with and
have fun maybe you're just too serious
you know maybe since you had the child
you just got serious all of a sudden you
did something what's wrong with you
you've got a child
do you want do you want more kids yeah
definitely with him I wouldn't be mad if
he was the dad but obviously I want to
find like
my right man and then that is all right
it's all over your face I
feel like when we say the right you pick
the right guy there's not like one one
person out there for you she just don't
want to put in the hard work to make him
perfect
but is it my responsibility to make you
perfect though is it his responsibility
to make you perfect I mean I don't think
there's any either of the responsibility
do you have a cookbook
I mean with your own recipes that you've
made yourself
what'd you mean you know what I mean I
just said it it's okay that was okay
it's you don't have to but I'm saying
like if you know if you're gonna
criticize and say it's my job to make
him perfect it's like am I perfect yeah
so I feel like it depends on who it is I
feel like that comes with
there's something in a relationship when
two people are immature and you're aware
of it that comes and established like
thing we're like cool we're going to be
immature but we know when to like you
said when to act right and and it's also
like it determines like what what is the
right time to act to act right who
determines that
both both parties got to you have to be
in a consensus for for anything but what
if you disagree
I follow you couldn't you couldn't agree
to disagree too
right but the whole point is you may
look at a situation and see it as he
needs to be serious now but he might
think that he doesn't have to then he
took it out and you'll be like listen I
don't appreciate it but what what was
Ashley trying to say and I was trying to
say that
some people will be immature to you by
feeling mature to them they can't take
it
so it's kind of like now you're stuck in
a position where you can't be immature
and now every time they're immature it's
kind of like that this is not the right
time you see that's why you don't play
games in relationships see that's what I
was trying to get because no having fun
and playing games is different
he was having fun what you describing is
playing games there's a big difference
because he was just being himself
um and she knows it was just being
himself so I'm in the foolish sometimes
they have fun I'm sure that women are
stupid sometimes too and they allow you
we're creating a new therapy Studio they
need to be able to handle the truth
tissues will be supplied
advice you're stuffing it
it's tough you know what I'm always
right and I'm proven wrong
um
so you want to prove me wrong fair
enough but I know that I can get you and
your mind working yeah that might need
you right now and get the next baby
yeah yeah we could do a couple episodes
yeah I mean yeah I want to see her on
that bloke
yeah
let's hear The Men's yeah
for them I think that once the Effigy
just shut up and listen to me you should
tell a few home truths you can bring the
musician too we can get you guys
[Laughter]
you just thought was the right thing to
do I mean but with hindsight would you
if he wasn't a musician what else could
he have been he was a architectural
metal worker in the airport and he was
miserable and I wanted him to be happy
okay so to be happy
he left his job and he took a risk and I
encouraged that didn't work out good for
him financially majorly so yeah oh
that's all right then we'll use that are
still friends and that's all right
you've got no kids with him yeah oh you
have well that's all right then he's
making money you got kids and you're
getting on that's great yeah
no arguments that's always good I really
I really think we could do a double
episode I really think we can just bring
families together in the theater
[Laughter]
do you know what I'd really like to do
I'd like to I'd like to follow her and
I'd like to check out her um
Style
because I reckon she's giving off the
wrong
I'd like to you know that wife's got I'd
like to make her over and see the
difference this young lady here
I think she's giving that all the wrong
I think she's attracting the wrong type
of person because she's giving out the
wrong signals
do you think how you look um affects the
type of person you know how you look how
you look how you present yourself
everything of course I honestly think
I'm a sexual object like when it comes
to things but do you allow it not that I
allow it but at the end of the day I
know if you do it you allow it
yeah you allow it the minute you do it
you allow it that's your choice how you
present yourself as well I understand
that to you you may not do it to be a
sexual object but people are going to
determine you as what you look like
people judge a book by its cover so
isn't that in your control yeah I don't
think so much is actually looks like I
think I think it's her behavior and the
way she talks first impressions as well
yeah I think it's her behavior not
really First Impressions we really talk
about the ugly man that I'd sleep with
so it's not about First Impressions
because it must be something underneath
all of his ugliness for me to sleep with
him so I just think that she can look as
she is but I think you can carry
yourself different and you can talk
differently I think that's what it is
okay and I'll prove myself right if you
put yourself in my hands do you wanna do
you want to come on an episode of wave
school yeah yeah wow we have so many
applicants here why
school oh yeah we do um it's just like
wife classes basically so things we're
basically training Pearl we were
training up Pearl to be wifey material
she's getting there and he didn't think
I was wife
but now she decides that she wants
everybody else to come in because I
think she's feeling a bit um
needed the bread well okay the bread
what did you have do you have to change
everything what have you had to change
since white school um
okay we have we have
different chapters okay this chapter I'm
in is cooking okay so I'm really trying
to be able to cook healthy food for a
family so
um I've been feeding my staff
blessings are they happy about that is
it working he's good
look yeah in the beginning I had some
mess-ups I won't lie but I've actually
improved a lot in the last like about
13. if you can cook can I just answer
the question Pearl yeah can I ask
everybody what's their um their favorite
meal to cook what meal if you had 15
minutes to cook what would you cook 15
minutes one five one five fifteen what
would you cook off the top of your head
what kind of pasta and what oh about
Bolognese okay what would you cook
sort of like chicken pasta with some
cream cheese something like that okay
what would you cooking lady just 15
minutes yeah oh my partner likes Can't
Be Fashion beetroot so it's pretty easy
okay 10 minutes literally
steak and eggs okay steak in 15 minutes
to cook my steak you have yours no it's
if you have a blue it's even less right
I like it I do like it blue I do like it
blue sometimes I like mine pink
so what would you call young lady
um I oh sorry I'd probably make fried
rice in 15 minutes that's probably what
I can make with them bit of chicken in
it vegetables peace
I would do okay I'm torn I either want
to do the sushi bowl or the jollof rice
but I just started doing the jollof rice
so I'm like I don't know if I can get it
in 15 minutes 15 minutes you could cook
jollof rice
I'm trying to teach you how to do a TV
you can do it in the rice cooker 15
minutes not the not the real one I've
done the railway that takes a lot longer
what is your favorite thing to make
cookies
I have a family like recipe that my
grandma tell my mom my mom taught me and
it's like cookies from scratch I like
that I'm a really big dessert person
it's not good
um but Auntie also just taught me a cake
that I really like making too it's not
so the things that are not good for her
yeah oh yeah tell me about it I had to
stop baking when I started losing weight
it was like well I can make a Victoria
sponge or I can lose no weight so it's
gonna be one of the other yeah I've had
the same realization recently yeah when
you get when you get a text at two
o'clock in the morning where are the
cookies there's no sugar in the house oh
my God
and then the next episode uh or next
month what are we doing fashion we're
doing fashion yeah and then the month
because I've always been a tomboy so
I've always really like I've just been
such a Tumblr I've just never keep
wearing it just right now I know it's
big for me
videos a year ago I was in sweats every
time I should see what he was wearing
that day when I cut your trousers up oh
yeah yeah and he like
um she cut my jeans because yeah because
she felt like they were ugly I'm pretty
late I'm pretty laid back How's that
gonna go ahead
they're really nice shorts
um and then after that what are we doing
etiquette yeah etiquette and then
that's gonna be hard
um and then dance and then yeah oh wow
dance as well yeah are you teaching
dance no we're probably getting it
probably get like an instructor or
something
but she'll have to whine she's been at
dancing already but she won't post it
she went to 60s Go-Go dancing oh no I
always I keep pressing it's so close oh
I'm sure you do
I've set her up I've said this to a
dance class when she got there she
realized what it was for yeah I love
that no I didn't know what go go dancing
was it was like a whole Community
they're like obsessed with the 60s yeah
and I was like they're like what do you
love about the 60s I'm like perfect
this class
no they were young actually most people
I would say were like 20s and 30s there
was like only one or two older ladies
wow yeah yeah they're mostly anyone else
taking an owl anyone else in
relationships yeah like a tooth that was
the L I took from the relationship I'm
out
I met you were you look back and you say
that you you lost
like you were not the winner you were
the loser
I think I've dumped every man that I've
ever been with and I've always won I'm
glad
yeah
it's good no one else
really wow
so I don't feel like I've lost in a
relationship I mean you're only 19.
yeah but yeah I don't yeah the thing is
I don't have too much to lose right do
you get it like other than emotional
damage
like drama probably like daily routine I
don't really have much to lose compared
to other people like money's not
involved in it family's not involved in
it friends barely you know
so to be fair I don't feel like I've
lost in a relationship why do you have a
relationship why do you what is it about
relationship why do you go into
relationship at such a young age
um I think I like having
someone there that I can confide in but
yeah I'm a teddy bear
[Music]
um I think mostly because
I like someone that can add on to my
lifestyle I like someone that I can at
the end of the day go back and be like
this is like this is my person kind of
like my best friend
um how's it working for you great
are you in a relationship now is it's
complicated but that's so great that
means no is it a yes or no nothing's
complicated or situation [__] some type
of situation ships complicated no are
you in relationship yes or no okay I am
not in a relationship I am in a I am in
a partnership which we're still figuring
stuff out
um I recently just tried to cut cut him
off
no
nah
um so I think it was more so we kind of
went cool like this is why I saw maybe
it was a bit of a hasty decision so we
can stay in until we try to figure out
what's up and if it's not meant to be
it's not meant to be but yeah that's a
lot for such a young age
yeah I feel like a lot of
younger generation feel like they need
to be in a relationship
um I've got two girls
um and my youngest feels like she needs
to be in a relationship and I don't I
don't get it but and where my job and
what I I work with children
a lot of young teenagers and adolescents
feel like they need
to be in a relationship it's quite scary
but I think I think more so than being
in a relationship I think it's more so
that you don't want to lose that person
so the only way you don't lose
the kind of go quite understand that
relationship I'm not saying that's the
that applies to me right now but that's
kind of like
well I think the general mindset is can
I give you a bit of advice my mom always
said to me um you know you said you
always want somebody to be there you
don't want to be on your own yeah my mom
would say you're not a twin yeah 100 so
if you're not a twin you should be used
to being on your own only twins need
somebody that will miss someone so get
over your loneliness and get out there
and get a hobby and stop being a man I
will admit that I could I do struggle to
be alone I will openly admit that and I
think more times right now I've
practiced being alone I think I don't
need that validation from someone else
to be like I can do this I can do that
but do you know I think that's a big
responsibility to put on somebody else
to not make you feel alone and to bring
you that kind of Happiness inside not
because I will never be like I would
never approach someone and be like yeah
like I need you to be there for me it's
just kind of what happens I don't end up
I don't think women are meant to be
alone
like I mean I I can understand like a
teenager you might not want them getting
in a relationship but it's it's it feels
really good being single I mean I mean
in the short term but I mean we've more
women on antidepressants than ever
before and we're more single than ever
before I agree with you I don't think
sorry I don't think women
are supposed to be alone
but men are not supposed to be
suffocated by a woman that can't handle
being alert
and I think that's the difference
until you're with someone be happy being
alone yeah and if you're not happy being
alone then the person that you're going
to be if you're gonna suffocate hell out
of him 100 percent yeah I wonder about
100 but yeah she was the man and she's
going to be with him just leave the man
rather than going back with him 100 no
because I agree with you no I'm I'm not
gonna say her and lie to you and say
I've been ignorant to everything I'll be
real like I'm a kind of person I have to
think everything through believe it or
not so if I'm gonna stay in something I
know why I'm gonna stay in it because it
works for me and it works for both of us
somewhat but it's also
um also at a point where it's kind of
like cool I can do whatever I want right
now this is a time for me to learn this
is the time for me to do whatever I want
to do and you know something right I
think that's the worst thing that mother
people say nowadays you think so is that
Now's the Time because I'm sure that all
the older people I'm saying oh they're
not like me older I wish they didn't do
that no if you if you can be if you
you're sensible or you sound sensible if
you're sensible now stop going in stupid
relationships sort yourself out and get
in one that works because you're talking
with a lot of sense so you know what
works so you know that don't work you
know
stop picking up crap pick up something
that you can study and I'm sure when you
keep on thinking a lot of you like oh
yeah that's what we need now but you can
if she had a way again she'd do it
differently if she was 18 or 19 we all
will and that's why I find that when you
get young people they don't think they
don't take advice from older people
because she just said why do they need
to be in a relationship there's no
reason for you to be in a relationship
unless you're gonna deal in relationship
to be serious to get married or
something like that because if I was
young now I think I'd be married at 19
or 20 and I think I'd be a virgin until
I was 19 or 20. knowing what I know now
um and I'm sure that anybody else who's
done it but everybody's nodding
everybody's nodding so
if you can't be in a relationship and
you can't see a future don't be in it
don't waste your time don't waste your
body don't waste your energy don't waste
your brain and don't waste his time
either
because you might get back together oh
once I'm getting what I know what stuck
out when you said somewhat we're getting
what we want somewhat that means that
you're not you're just hanging on in
there until something better comes along
until you get bored and dump him get out
of it hmm
I was gonna say about you know you said
people are antidepressants so in my work
what I find is that it's people are
living unnaturally people are stuck on
their phones people eating the wrong
diet a lot of processed food a lot of
junk and that actually is a causal
um contributor to depression so I find
people that come to me for coaching and
I found with myself once I changed my
diet my depression my anxiety completely
went and I was in the same situation so
it was nothing to do with being in a
relationship not being in a relationship
who was around me it was me and the food
that I was eating the inflammation I was
causing within my body and then stopping
that sorry go ahead and sort of reverse
in that and then not having to deal with
that note any longer no I think that's a
good point I definitely think diet is a
part of it do you do typically think
women that are 50 child childless and
single are typically happy
no no and I think that that's part of
the agenda the feminist the gender isn't
it and the agenda was put in place
apparently so that they could then start
taxing
women as well instead of just taxing the
man they now have a household where they
can tax two people two people were
working they make life a bit harder it
makes it harder for the family to stay
together the family's not staying
together you weaken Society we weaken
Society you can control Society you can
control the population so why don't you
eat vegetables because they're they
cause inflammation
especially especially the green leafy
ones don't stop especially because so
they have they have anti-nutrients okay
multiple anti-nutrients one of the worst
is um oxalates and you'll find that in
spinach you'll find that in almonds
you'll find that in many plant foods and
actually that's so bad too yeah
um so if you if you're thinking of not
having arthritis you want to avoid those
what's wrong with the airfryer no off
fries
some things that are produced like uric
acid like stiffness
[Laughter]
so vegetables are better this is good so
can I excuse me I'm young lady do you
believe what would you rather
take 10 pills a day that somebody's
giving you to say these are what you
need or eat a veg
I would eat meat and not take no I mean
if you had to eat veg or take these all
these tablets
what are you what do you eat in a day
can I have like a you like steak and
eggs put and I'll let you have steaks do
you really want to hear it you're
probably gonna be shocked okay go ahead
go ahead so for breakfast I regularly
have 10 eggs 10 eggs and I started
boiling them because there's no mess
they come out perfect and they're soft
in the middle
um for lunch I might have 10 eggs again
or I might have some sort of
burger patty I eat a lot steak
um chicken chicken fries sometimes I
don't ever go for chicken breast because
that's just dry and disgusting yeah
right no wrap it in bacon wrap it in
streaky bacon yeah it's still dry once
you go once you've got no once you go
all red meat it's different
because I'm just I'm struggling to wrap
my head around no vegetables because as
an athlete I'd kind of have to oh yeah
so you'd do better you think so yeah I
know because I'm kind of like how does
that work so I work for a doctor who is
56. he is he lives in America and he is
world champion at Rowan at 56. he has
improved his strength and he's been
Carnival seven years
um and he has improved everything he got
rid of all of his illnesses wasn't it I
mean for that diet that came up years
ago that used to be called zero carb
then it went to carnivore diet
um but you know it's just I mean before
that I'm sure there was somebody that
just say it will meet there was a diet
going around years ago oh yeah it's
called um the lion diet oh and the lion
diet yeah
do you mean Primal no
I can't remember what it was but this
guy was just eating me on there he was
just slapping up the meat front at the
meat I like him
guy liver oh liver King yeah he lied
though didn't he he lied a lot wait so
10 eggs then 10 eggs again maybe the
mistake do you know what I can
understand the state where the hell do
you put 10 eggs I can't eat two eggs
really no yeah but what you eat you eat
to what your what you need nutrition
you're talking boiled yeah I can manage
one
do your kids eat only meat too I would
love them too but no they have varied
diet they do but they don't actually
want they're just such they like fruit
and I don't matter so there's some
stories so when they were younger I used
to make them eat their veg and um they
come up with some really good ideas of
how to hide their Vegeta sometimes they
quickly open a window and hide it in the
barbecue or or they'd quickly put it
under the table and then I would
um assume it was the wrong child and
make the other child pick it up and eat
it
and the other one just let them do it
yeah so now they're thankful they're
like yeah so it's eggs
a lot of eggs chicken a lot of red meat
lamb is my favorite wow the Lamb's
expensive right now
you should you would love it in Morocco
I have venison the other day
all right sorry
there's a local there's a local Hunter
who actually
um so you know there's a vegan argument
that actually is wrong to kill animals
well I have someone who is a hunter
that's local actually he goes to the
crop fields and he has to protect the
vegetables and he shoots all the deer
and whatever else there and then I
managed to get a hold deer for 25 pounds
can I have one which is nice
how long have you been doing the diet so
in April it's four years wow wow do you
have like a before and after yes is it
on your yes wait can you can we pull it
up but I know this is off topic I'm just
like really I'm curious
there's a there's a video you'd have to
play the video okay could you play it I
just yeah I just want to be honest for
myself okay honestly okay and I'm also
really excited that vegetables are bad
for you they are so do you like this one
don't get your crutches
about getting the crutches out
do you know what it is right she came
back from America with a load of pills
oh okay right and I said do not take I
don't believe in taking all these
supplements I'd rather you have
meat and two veg oh so it's supplements
yes yeah so yeah yeah you need to be you
don't need supplements I don't take no
supplements okay so I actually consider
salt a supplement which is because it's
strange that I sold a lot do yeah rice
no do it what do you say do you use that
no bread no carbs is it on your
Instagram yeah
I've been doing it about a year I lost
weight I have fell off track a couple of
times and I do cheat but I've I feel
better than I've ever felt so where's
the before
oh you skip past the before the before
is first yeah what are you doing
it's just perfect come on wow oh wow so
that was during
oh my God you look completely different
you do yeah a lot of Happy Food a lot of
butter a lot of butter
and
actually not much exercising to be
honest but how often do you exercise Oh
there's uh so I used to before
lockdowns I dance sometimes in my heart
this is embarrassing
oh God
I mean I'm just like sure that's good if
you're interested give me a call
when you said supplements are bad are
you referring to all vitamins or because
personally I take creatine and collagen
so were they look you know bad for me
then it depends what collagen and
creatine you're taking but um
[Music]
I don't get a specific one collagen from
my protein is very good oh good yeah
it's really clean it's got nothing in it
if you go to other places that have soy
in it and things you don't want to have
soy yeah you want to avoid soy affects
your estrogen levels especially in men
um but yeah I got collagen just because
when I lost weight my hair started
falling out because you know your
nutrients go from there to there and so
just wondering how it is you must have
been cutting your calories quite drastic
see for me my weight loss happened
whilst I was eating four to five
thousand calories a day I did my weight
loss didn't happen by starving myself I
literally eat until I'm bursting right
on that eats who I'm bursting then I
started I was writing that I tell Pearl
she doesn't eat enough she needs to eat
three times a day and snack any of my
clients the under e don't lose weight
yeah see I was right right on that yeah
she was leading me astray with the
vegetable yes she was she was
happy
for nothing what were the supplements oh
I don't even they're too oh there's some
great big pessary looking things they're
massive she got from America you know
you know Americans and stuff are full of
rubbish my mom my mom gave it to me I
was like okay I'll try it
but yeah about what you were um saying
about calorie counting just because you
know I am
because you said you were using about
four five thousand regularly over five
thousand well well for me
um I had to figure out what my
maintenance calories were
um and I just I started off at 330
pounds which is absolutely insane
thinking about it now
um and gradually you know my calories
went down from you know 3 000
maintenance to 2500 so you know lower
and lower until about 1500 which is too
low for me it's not because um it is
it's too late and you will do damage
stuff yourself long term
well there's different ways of doing it
I mean not ever sorry I've kind of
overtaken everything but the meat thing
isn't for everyone I think it would
benefit everyone but mentally people
can't do it
um
every client that I coach
reverses all their health issues some of
them my clients go from being completely
bed-bound to then be able to be up and
exercising and doing things this isn't
cutting calories so a lot of my clients
go from 900 calories a day and I
increase it some some of those increase
it to 5000 and they start losing weight
when they're at 900 calories they
stopped you reduce your metabolism when
you do that yeah and then every time
you've got to keep cutting it back and
cutting it back to try and make a little
bit of loss well what you're losing
essentially then when you're under
eating is 50 muscle and 50
um fat so well for me um because I know
it varies with everyone you know weight
loss and health isn't linear which it
would be easier if it was
um but as I've gradually you know lost
the weight because I do this thing
called a body composition obviously
you're into fitness you'll know what it
is that's the scan
um it's essentially where it measures
your muscle compared to your fat and
your hydration
um with being on 1500 calories don't get
me wrong you know there are days where I
go over but I pretty comfortably stay on
that and
from my body composition my muscle has
gone upwards on the you know graph and
my fat has gone lower for me you know
perhaps you're right perhaps it will
change for me but someone who's had
issues with food growing up
um I I just want to make sure I can
maintain a healthier weight obviously
I'm not healthy now I've lost
it now 122 which is amazing yeah which
is amazing but the the dexa scans and
all those scans are not accurate and
actually if you drink water before you
do one of those scans it will show you a
higher body
um muscle mass I read that I thought it
was been bad with hydration so nine
times out of ten I've not drunk water
before so what I'm saying is they're not
accurate so it's not a it's not a good
way to determine actually calipers are
much more accurate so I just trust you
think right that
just eat
a balanced diet
no problems
but no processes
no processed foods and the best quality
foods that you can buy yeah I agree I
think that's what it is but if you're
gonna buy steak I had a steak and it was
massive and it was really good and it
was like 30 quid and I cooked it outside
in the garden
because that was the instructions you
had to get a skilly and like eat you
really up with loads of butter and it
was all smoking and I like my medium and
that's all I could eat was just the one
steak because there was no room for
anything else but I just think a
balanced diet and eat often that I don't
I don't watch calories I don't watch
calories I eat what I want and um I
think Grandma's gonna eat more other
than you say more than most people but
not more than ever I like to eat a lot
it's like not rubbish food no processed
stuff I agree with everything but eating
regularly eating regularly is just gonna
spike your insulin
um fat storage hormone that's not a good
thing so if you can eat enough in each
meal to sustain you I so I eat three
meals a day that's that's fine and I
don't need to eat any more than three
meals a day I'm full up yeah that's
regular free meals a day yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying um so and some
people think you need to eat six times a
day but that's just spiking your insulin
I'm trying to get helped me three times
a day yeah you do yeah and I have a hard
time doing three yeah
I was gonna ask what would So based on
like my circumstances as I've said
because I you know gradually gone down
from you know three thousand to about
fifteen hundred and when I've because
I've actually gone to 1700 and I like
consistently gained weight from that
um so you know as someone who is a
trainer what would your like opinion be
if I'm losing consistently not losing
loads at 1500 I'm losing a pound a week
but I'm losing it consistently okay so
first I would say throw away the scales
second I would say you need to do a
reverse diet where you increase the
calories you need to trust the process
you need to allow your body to fire up
again and get everything working you
know when you're starving yourself your
natural ability to know when you're
hungry and know when your foot is
Switched Off
so you need to get all those things in
your body working again
um that's not what everybody's saying
well these women would they can't have
an obese man no yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't because he is not taking care
of himself he's unhealthy I mean
naturally if you think back years any
animal goes for another animal mate
because they're healthy why would we go
for someone that's not and what if they
didn't know how to be healthy like say
somebody didn't know how to cook they
had to do that I'm a strategist but if I
thought he was cute I'd just feed him
less
you can't you can't build a man
no I just wondered like you know no in
general what do you mean obese do you
mean someone who looks particularly
overweight because
certain people are somebody maybe not
actually somebody we need to talk about
the BMI on that skill they're obese on
the BMI
uh so you can get that from a
bodybuilder even that's got no they can
be so the the BMI is not a good but I
mean I wouldn't get a bodybuilder
because I think they're too big so
that's what I mean so would you go with
somebody that's flabby then fat and
flabby not built yeah
she said yeah
you have been the master
have you ever been has anybody ever been
out with somebody oh boy other than us
[Laughter]
[Music]
free
no but I just wanted because sometimes I
find that the women will not mind the
men taking them and they're fat and
overweight but they won't take them in
when they're fat and overweight
the women that go with the men and say
yeah I'm fine I'm going to lose weight
or they put on weight and they say I
want to lose weight I'm going to get fat
[Music]
it's like nothing I just wanted to put
it out there
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second
um and then we'll probably close out the
show and do final thoughts
um guys make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel those are the
most important metrics that YouTube uses
to push out these live streams so do we
get 2 000 likes I think we're close
aren't we
also guys
um we're looking at doing the one
million party this summer it's a lot
harder to plan an event than I initially
realized so if you guys have any input
on location let me know in the chat
hold on I'm pulling up the super chats
okay
um escape the prison Colony um Auntie is
at Atkins diet that's it that's the one
okay thank you
Ryerson bless you ladies um tell 9265
ladies there's no such thing as the
right man or Soul soulmate you pick and
then you put in the work to make it
right fairy tales aren't real life puffy
Vegas I am dyslexic what I'm trying to
say is that I never saw
um domestic violence um tongue rusby
ladies you need to pick better and do
better and understand that love comes
last in a relationship in marriage Duty
and respect comes first always puffy
Vegas I was born in 1974 I never saw any
DV I because I grew up in a very
traditional uh and a very traditional
black I grew up in a very traditional
large black it's all Bs the UK Economist
see what happens when women go after the
tingles rather the man's values they
make poor choices escape the prison
Colony girl on the Green Top sorry from
a man's perspective and as someone who
has shown my emotions a hundred percent
of the time within the month the
relationship was over the UK Economist
women claim that they want a good
husband and father for the family but
why do so many women choose men who are
the exact opposite Dragon stallion one
zero zero one what do what do you offer
in a relationship other than the poom
poom and got gok 3000.
[Music]
um
you know what that is
that you don't know you don't know what
that is Auntie no because the men with
you you're going to explain it you know
I would rather not I'll tell you later
Fanny flutter equals Chad and Tyrone uh
Doug MPA Tom Tom Brady wait wait guys
guys make sure guys guys guys guys wait
auntie auntie baby
um
um okay Tom Brady has a 375 million
dollar ESPN contract now a more the kids
lose out and our mentality and are
mentally screwed forever ever sadly
Master Fox I feel like merch and Let me
refresh it just to make sure there
aren't any more
um
okay last one Brighton been a great
conversations you you guys have made my
night
um also guys next week I'm doing the
show
um Friday Thursday and Friday I have an
away game so I'm not going to be there
Saturday so tune in Thursday and Friday
next week so
um to close the show everyone put your
final thoughts any Instagram so you guys
want to plug social media go ahead
starting here and then go around final
thoughts what am I allowed to address
any of the comments right now yeah go
ahead oh for someone that that came at
me saying whatever they said right
listen I'm sorry that happened to you
right because I'm sure if I'm sure if in
another parallel universe we got along
and you cried to me I wouldn't do that
to you so maybe it's about the woman but
um no on a real one I'm actually uh I do
apologize for that I think everybody
should be able to communicate the
emotions without feeling the need or
with that feeling that they've they're
not on the right or feel like they they
should have brought up in the first
place because let me tell you one thing
if you bring up a problem and someone
and a man tells you or anybody tells you
that or makes you feel a way that you
could then go oh you know why should
I've done it then the manipulating you
but yeah and for us for final thoughts
um well that's all I've got to say but I
hope
I wish well in everybody's relationship
and yeah
yeah that's what I've got to say to me
so it's my Instagram s-a-m sbr00
um that is my Instagram
so you guys can follow me on there if
anything
great go ahead final thoughts are I
enjoyed the chat I think I like the way
it went off topic a few different times
um my Instagram is carnivore.fitness
got me thinking about
meet me I do it should I do it yeah I'll
coach I'll be your coach I'll catch you
I help you
um
yeah I really enjoyed this um I'll
definitely take into consideration
um you know about perhaps changing my
diet I probably got thrilled away the
scales but I'll definitely consider
changing the diet
um I've won a school in the show for
quite a while because I've religiously
watched the show so yeah it's been
really good thank you for having me
thanks for coming
um my last final thoughts I really
enjoyed the chat
um
it was nice to hear from such wonderful
other women as well here about their
opinions on relationships as well
um
and um I've been announced my
Instagram's common dot boo fest97
thanks for having me Pearl Auntie Jenny
on YouTube
I enjoyed it you gotta you gotta start
plugging it yeah
your Instagram too it's um was it Jenny
to Auntie English spelling
oh Auntie Jimmy says whatever it is it's
out there
um
yeah
thanks for having me Phil
um thank you for having me for one um it
was unexpected
um I appreciate having me uh
my Instagram is divine.lotus.yoga
um and thank you for everyone else
thanks for having me it's been an
experience are you coming to therapy
next week
I think he would come
I'll make him gosh
I'll make him come but um you're free
what time you want to do it this week
Auntie anytime she's ready you just let
us know the date and the time we're
ready okay we have a therapy chair in
the back too you guys
[Laughter]
lying down they can stand
no but yeah it's been good
um
yeah just like do what makes you happy
guys in this life that's what you have
to do in stuff yeah insta is re.mj so
a-r-i-e dot MJ
flash by Ling underscore for the last
page
a couple announcements before we end the
show
um the first is that we have two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you guys go subscribe to
both
um also guys we have four membership
tiers the first gets you into the chat
the second is our behind the scenes
Vlogs as well as our Discord
um third tier connects with me on social
media and fourth tier is a one-on-one
call with me once a month I really
recommend this if you're trying to grow
on YouTube especially if you want to do
a live show I can give you guys so many
insights save you a lot of time
um
I my Instagram just probably things won
also also they took away my first second
third and fourth Tick Tock so go follow
just pearlythings.5 I'm trying to get to
like 250k on there so before they take
it away again
um subscribe to wife school that should
be in the description
um also we have a rumble now
um and just pearly animations and also
guys we only have one pre-game Instagram
so these pop-up accounts on Instagram
they're not there's just one that's the
pregame show
and yeah thank you guys so much for
watching um put in the comments what
topics you want us to cover next week
like the video on your way out subscribe
to this Channel and I'll see you next
week
thank you bye